welcome
to the next part of the tutorial
forecasting big time series theory and
practice
in this part we will look at some other
neural network architectures for
forecasting models
in particular we will look at
convolutional neural networks
transformers and the n-beats model
so we start with convolutional
neural networks
what are convolutional neural networks
well they are neural networks that use
convolutional layers
so in typical convolutional neural
network models
these architectures combine different
convolutional layers with other
types of layers such as feed-forward
networks
and these convolutional neural networks
have been
very successful in computer vision
applications
because they allow us to encode
[Music]
spatial invariants which are
important for for images and this allows
us to
use much fewer parameters than you would
use otherwise in a in in a with a
feed-forward
neural network
and similarly for one-dimensional
problems so for time series models
you can use convolutions one-dimensional
convolutions
which then encode temporal invariance
so this means when we shift the time
series by a certain way and in by a
certain number of
units then uh these convolutions
preserve the the output essentially
um and this is what we an expectation
that we often
have and
in the same sense as for these images
this reduces the number of parameters
that the model has to learn and allows
us to
learn better models essentially
so let us look at how these
convolutional layers
work in detail
so here we have a sequence of values
which would be our our time series
and the convolutions
work by just
combining these observations in a linear
way so we just use a linear combination
of these inputs so in this case we have
three
three values that we combine so this is
what we
refer to as kernel width three
and we just create a linear combination
as the output so here you see uh
this is just a linear mapping and
um what we what the model
will learn are these weights
[Music]
it is often here important that
for instance for the first input we
we may not yet have enough values from
the target sequence
depending on how much into the future we
want to predict
and so sometimes it's necessary to
include padding
so here we may pat with zero values
but you could also pad with other types
of values or
have a separate indicator separate
variable that
indicates this this padding and
gives that as a variable to the model
um so let's look at a bit more detail
um what how these convolutions look like
for
forecasting models there are two types
of
convolutions in one dimension
one is non-causal convolutions which is
essentially which means we combine these
these values here using these linear
weights
into our output and the output index
corresponds to
the same time index as the input so this
could be used to
smoothen the signal or for some other
models
but in in forecasting applications we're
often
interested in predicting the next value
um and then this is what we what we call
a
causal convolution so here because
causality means
we we only take information
before the current time point into
account
for this output in the future
so this is the the causal part of that
so as i mentioned before um
convolutions here and um
are kind of shift invariant and how this
works
uh becomes clear when we look at
um how the convolutions um are applied
to a whole sequence
so here we start off with uh just the
padding values
so we have three padding values which
are all zero um
we have these weights and here the
output would also be 0 in this case
and then for the next value that we want
to compute
this convolution kernel is shifted by
one time point
so now we combine these three values to
compute this output value and
so on and so on so in this manner we
just
shift the convolutions uh one step ahead
to compute the the next time point
what is important here is that these
weights are
the same um during this whole process
so this is what makes a convolution um
different from a feed-forward model
we could also have a feed-forward model
which would just
combine these inputs but then these
weights would not be
the same at each time step and
this immediately shows how convolutions
reduce the number of parameters and at
the same time
encode this shift in variance that
is important for time series models
so one problem with the previous
approach
is that
that this may need
um a lot of processing to compute
to look back very far into the past
so if we go back let's say we want to
look back
we have a a time series with maybe
minutely data
and we want to uh look back one week ago
then we can imagine we need this um a
kernel
or this filter width to
reach back the full history one week ago
which means we
we create a lot of these a lot of these
weights and we have lots of parameters
and if you want to look back further so
maybe
you have hourly data and want to look
back a year then this
this could become very very large
so this is one problem with with these
standard convolutions
but there are alternative models which
use convolutions in a different manner
and one of these
models is one of these approaches is a
what's called a dilated causal
convolution
and one very popular model
that is that makes use of these is the
wavenet model by fun and ort at al
and this is a model that's used for
speech synthesis but it's essentially
very similar
to a forecasting model so it's a
generative model that predicts
the the waveform for the speech signal
at the next time point and
these dilated convolutions work by
skipping skipping uh
connections in
further layers so what you see here is
how
is basically the connection structure of
this network we have
multiple layers here and in the lowest
layer
we don't skip any any um
any points any time points so
each time point contributes to the the
value
that we compute in this step but at the
higher layers
we um we skip basically a few time
points
and this is what's referred to as
dilated convolutions
so this allows us to with just very few
layers and
few convolutions to have basically an
exponential reach into the past and
with very few parameters we can reach
very far back and which allows us to
to learn models with with very long
seasonalities for instance
so for these speech synthesis
that's a very common problem if you
look at correlations in the speech
signal they reach very far back and this
is exactly why
such a model is important there so in
this model
the forecasts uh or the prediction for
the next time point are generated in an
auto regressive fashion so at each
time point we generate a prediction for
the next time point and then
we can if we want to
predict further into the future we can
roll this
forward
this type of model can of course also be
be used in other contexts so
we can use this as an encoder or as a
decoder in sequence to sequence model so
this is uh what jan showed in his slides
and um the the exact structure of how
these convolutions look like or how
these uh building blocks here look like
uh there's this can be very complicated
so we could have
uh in in this in this wavenet model
there is a very complicated structure
here
uh for for these individual elements but
this is the overall
um idea of of these dilated causal
convolutions
so here is an uh is a more detailed
animation of how this would look like
so to compute the next time point we run
these convolutions forward
and then we generate the prediction for
the next time point and
use that as an input so that's the
typical autoregressive
approach for for generating
predictions of many times steps ahead
and one thing that is maybe not so clear
from these images
is that each of these computations that
we run here
can actually be recomputed so reused
so if we when we run a prediction for
the next time point
this computation has already been
executed
and actually we can just reuse that so
this makes the the architecture
efficient and in general it
the possibility that all that we can
compute
all these convolutions in parallel that
is
one of the main advantages of
convolutional neural networks in general
if you think back about the rnn
structure
this is a completely sequential approach
where
where to compute the next time point
we actually have to run the previous
time point
uh the computation for that and we have
to wait before
to for that to finish before we can
compute anything else
in this case we can run all these
computations in parallel
which makes this very efficient at least
during training
if we run this in an auto regressive way
for predictions we still have to do some
computation in a sequential manner
but at least during training everything
is nicely parallelizable
which makes these models very efficient
on
gpus and that's one of the main
advantages
that these models have and why people
like them
so what about attention attention models
are another type of neural network
models which are very successful
in natural language processing and
natural language processing so for
example
machine translation as this example here
shows
are in many respects similar to
time series forecasting problems because
they deal with one-dimensional sequences
and
so we can we can think about applying
the ideas from from natural language
processing
to forecasting and one of these ideas
which has been very successful is
the attention mechanism how this works
is that we have an
encoder and a decoder
and they are linked through an attention
mechanism
and the attention mechanism works by
creating by using three
three specific feature vectors
one is called the key one is called the
query
and one is called the value and
so for instance to generate a a word in
this
machine translation problem here
the attention model would create a
a query vector here
for this at this time point
and each of the previous each of the
input
words uh have a um a
key feature vector and then
this attention mechanism decides based
on the query and the key which of these
words to focus on which of these words
to attend to
and this then generates combines the
value vectors from the past to make the
prediction for this time point so
the advantage of this approach is that
the model can learn
to look at certain things in the
sequence
based on the current input
so for example in theory you could
imagine in a time series
forecasting setting the model could
learn to look at
last year's easter
at when when the current time point
that you want to predict is also easter
so
in this sense the model can really learn
which
part of the sequence is important for
the current prediction which
part of the sequence one should look at
and here in this
machine translation model you can look
at these
attention maps which tell you for the
the output at a certain for a certain
word
which words in the input sequence did
the
input sequence did the model attend to
which of these
words were important so here these
attention
is this attention map and this
essentially expresses
this notion of the model
looking at certain parts of the input
sequence
for the current prediction
so what about attention
mechanisms for forecasting well
one very simple uh kind of attention
um has been used
for a long time in or it's not really an
attention mechanism but
it's it's a similar way of looking at
past values
and this has been used in forecasting in
many different contexts
and the idea is essentially that
for a prediction at a certain time point
we
feed in values lacked values of the
sequence
for the model to make a prediction at
this time point
and the reason why this works often in
time series problems and in forecasting
problems is
that we usually know which values will
be important because we know
the seasonalities of of the time series
so if i have a time series with
hourly data then i know that the the
time points around 24 hours ago
are important and maybe those uh
48 hours ago and maybe one week ago
so in this sense it's in for
seasonal time series it's we have a
notion of
which seasonalities are important and
then we
one approach is to just feed these
lacked values directly to the model
to make a prediction and this works very
well in many
in many applications so for instance
this uh
web traffic forecasting competition from
kaggle
was won by a neural network model
which uses these kind of lacked values
so in this sense you can argue
an attention mechanism um is maybe more
powerful
but if you already know the
seasonalities and if you already know
which
seasons seasonalities are important it's
maybe
the advantages maybe not that large
but uh nevertheless there have been
uh different experiments with uh
with attention-based models for
forecasting
and one such
model architecture that has been tried
for forecasting
is the so-called transformer model
so the transformer model was introduced
in this paper
also in the context of new of
natural language processing and the
transformer model is a model which only
uses attention
essentially there is no rnn
that runs along the sequence everything
is based on
layers and layers of attention and this
model
has has been very successful for
natural language processing and
it has in the meantime also been applied
to to forecasting problems
so in this paper the authors show
that you can apply the transformer
architecture to forecasting problems so
here
we see the what what i discussed
previously
there is a query vector a value vector
and a key vector and this is used to
combine
to decide which part the model
looks at in the history so for example
maybe if there's a certain pattern here
the model could
decide to look at similar patterns in
the history
to make the prediction
so one problem that forecasting
or time series problems have compared to
natural language processing is that
the sequences are often much longer so
in natural language processing typically
people will look at sentence sentences
sequences so a sequence of a single
sentence
um and then the sequence length is not
that long um so there may be i don't
know
um less than 100 words definitely
whereas in forecasting uh problems
you easily end up with thousands of time
points
and one problem that this um this
this then gives us that these attention
models become very expensive
uh because the when the sequence length
grows
so they become very compute intensive
and
um and memory intensive and
the authors here propose a uh what they
call lock spars
attention mechanism where
the attention mechanism does not look at
each individual value
um in the past but maybe it looks at
at closer distances in the near near
past
but the further um the further back the
values are
the uh the fewer
uh values it looks at and
another uh another problem that
the authors observed was that when when
they do this
the model is very prone to individual
outliers because
if it just looks at a single value um
that may be
maybe an anomaly for instance and then
it could could react too much to that
and so they also apply convolutions here
that
cause the convolutions to kind of
smoothen
this out a bit and to get some
contextual information
into this model
another approach that has recently been
proposed
in this paper is a
different approach this is the so-called
n-beats model and this model
uses a uses a basis expansion
analysis to generate
forecasts so this is an an interesting
model what
the model does is it it creates
so-called back casts and forecasts so
at each time point it it tries to
express the history of the
um of the time series in terms of some
basis functions so these could be
polynomials or
four-year features so it does basically
a decomposition of the
time series into some basis function and
then
it handles these it just expresses this
whole
history in terms of basis coefficients
and so this look back period here where
the back cast is generated
essentially we the model tries to
express
the history in terms of these basis
functions and then
predict the basis function or the
coefficients
for the future so this is how um
how how this looks like and um
so uh another interesting approach here
is that um it does
it applies kind of a stack of residual
models to do that so the first model
would
kind of predict um get the input of the
time series and
and handle that and then
whatever this back cast and forecast
look like
um the the back cast will be uh
subtracted from the actual
sequence to leave kind of an error
signal
um or in this in this look back period
and this is then the input
to the next layer and so
the next layer does the same thing it
tries to express
the look back period the time series in
this in this window
via this basis function
expansion and again the um
the residual so the the error signal is
propagated further
on the for the output
all these these forecasts
are then kind of summed up to give a
a general a combination of all these
individual forecasts
or of these residuals and
in addition the the authors also
apply an ensemble of these models so
this uses basically not just one of
these models but
but many and by doing so
um of course ensembling can also can
always
improve the accuracy
and the authors of authors observe that
in the m4 forecasting competition most
of the
the uh the methods that scored high
were ensemble methods and so their
approach to this is basically
to build an ensemble of these neural
networks
one maybe also interesting comment here
is that
the these residual blocks allow
the model to have many many layers so
this is a
common approach that has also been used
in computer vision for instance
where if you were to use a feed-forward
model where the input
to the next model is just to the next
layers just
layered on each other so basically you
just have a feed forward model
you usually cannot go very deep
with very deep architectures so
maybe five or six layers is the most you
can get
the problem is that your the gradients
from the
loss function that you compute have to
propagate through the
entire stack and this makes it very hard
to train these deep architectures
however if you use residuals what
happens is that
each of these blocks has a direct
connection to
the loss to the output as well as to the
input
so they all get a direct gradient
and that makes it much easier to train
deep architectures
so and in this n-beats model i think the
authors
have up to 150 layers here
which would be impossible to train with
simple feed-forward models
so we have a lot of neural network
models
so the question is maybe when to use
what
for which types of time series
so um this is
still open an open
research problem in general
but maybe the the current status could
be
summed up as follows so mlp
so just feed forward models are robust
baseline models
but they often need feature engineering
to to work but then if you have the
the right features engineered they can
give very good accuracies
rnns are the de facto standard models
for sequences
they however have some downsides in
particular
sometimes the training can be tricky
and they are not as efficient as other
model types
during training because they cannot make
use of gpus for parallelization as much
as
cnns can do
so some research in
neural networks basically advocates that
convolutional neural networks are as
accurate as
rnn's on many tasks but are
more efficient and the whole field
is is basically to some extent
moving from rnns to cnns
because of the efficiencies but
for uh yeah for many many
use cases rnns are still are still very
competitive some people also argue that
dilated rnns are just as efficient and
there are lots of hybrid
models between cnns and rnns
these transformer-based models that that
i showed before are also promising
models
and yeah i think there there will be
probably some more interesting research
in this
in this area
so we do not yet know which of these
architectures is the best
model but we will hopefully find out
so uh these
modern neural network models look great
and
seem to solve all our problems but
um there are still cases where
these models really are not well suited
for so in particular they struggle with
what we call the strategic strategic
forecasting problems
so for example if we want to predict
the overall amazon retail demand years
into the future
this is not a forecasting problem where
we have where we can use large amounts
of data
to generate forecasts there
there is too little training data
available
the training data is basically outdated
um
and we we need to put in a lot of um
maybe economic assumptions um uh
to to get a good good forecast
and in these sorts of applications where
you
just have one time series that you want
to predict and maybe
you care about this time series a lot um
classical forecasting models are often
much much better
just because um yeah there's so little
data
and if you care about the time series
you can invest a lot of time
into tuning your models on this time
series
where the neural network models really
shine
are kind of these operational
forecasting problems
so these are problems where we have
lots and lots of time series available
so for example
let's say we want to predict the demand
for each product
available at amazon then
each time series on its own is very
irregular
and the a local forecasting model
a classical forecasting model may have a
very hard time
looking at at this history and generate
anything meaningful
whereas neural network models or other
models that make use of
of these of these many time series
they can essentially learn that when
a time series when a product starts and
has this type of history
maybe when christmas is coming there
will be a peak and
this is typically how demand evolves so
this is where
these type of models really shine where
you have lots and lots of data of
similar things similar time series that
you want to predict
then the models can learn across all
these time series
how predictions how to predict a single
time series well well
so thank you for listening to this part
and
and i hope you enjoy the next part
thank you